everybody welcome back to another four
on our video and I guess I kind of
forgot something there in the dead
stream which is kind of the reason I'm
making this video apparently like
halfway through the dev stream or
something like that there was a picture
of the new rarity system and how it's
going to work out with the whole what
type of gear you will lock at a certain
rap I'll show the picture on the screen
now but this was shown in the dev stream
I guess I completely forgot or at least
I didn't see it it's kind of talked
about what we're seeing here basically
on the left hand side we're seeing the
present season season one and then in
the next on the right we're going to be
seeing season two in the next week or so
but as it says for season one you get
common items from rep zero all the way
up to rep to cut a rare items from rep
one to rep six and heroic items from rep
three all the way up to rep 30 now this
is kind of nice I like the way they laid
this out at least giving us an answer
here but I feel that a lot of people in
the community were kind of complaining
how they are what rep 6 in this chart
for example you could be rep 6 and
you're still getting blue items you
don't need blue items but the time your
rep sticks you probably have 108 gear
score by now and blue items are
practically useless for you so I'm glad
they did update it and add the new type
of rarity that will increase the gear
score limit so now common items drop
from reps from rep zero to two rares are
from 1 to 4 heroic is 3 to 6 and epics
are 5 to probably level 30 until they
change it again if they add more items
in the future I like the way that they
did this it's making it so that all the
top tier players at level 30 or anywhere
higher don't have to just base it gives
them another incentive to play again to
get the better items and then they're
not also wasting their time getting
items at these certain ranks as it's
then now for me I am a rep 6 level 3
Kenzi so I'm going to be getting a fair
assortment of heroic and epic year
whereas last season I would be getting a
fair assortment of rare and heroic gear
so I do like the way they did this
though I just want to hear your opinion
something else that came up a couple
weeks ago a youtuber by the name of own
nickel is a overwatch youtuber he was
explaining how the Chinese government
a law or made a law so that any game
with an orangy system such as over
watches loot boxes would they would have
to display the percentages of the chance
of getting a blue box because I guess I
guess a couple companies were saying
that there was items in the game but
there was no chance of them getting it
they're basically scamming players for
their money so they're making every game
that I guess available in China to do
that now I don't exactly know a for
honor is in China or not I'd obviously I
don't live in China I don't speak
Chinese so I wouldn't know if the game
is available in China or any Chinese
players are there but I'm assuming if it
is in China there is going to be a
statement somewhere talking about the
the percentage of how how much or what
the percentages of us getting epoch gear
in a scavenger crate at some type of
like rep six versus rep five or
something like that and I want to hear
your guy's opinion on that I think
that's kind of cool in my opinion I like
how they're doing it with these new
armors and such and they're all like I
said they're adding the the four new
weapons and the two new armors per hero
I do not exactly know what they are to
be honest they never did mention what
they were there was a ton of stuff going
on the dev stream that I did cover
though this is the one thing I guess I
missed anyways it's going to be really
the end of the video I hope you all did
enjoyed this short little thing that I
made for you all I'm sorry I did miss
this on Thursday I will kind of to do
that again but anyway boys I'll see you
I'll see you all later and I will see
you in when Thursday right I would see
well Thursday for the dev stream like if
you did enjoy dislike it if you didn't
subscribe if you are new to this channel
I always do a bunch of four on our
videos so be hugs for that stuff and
peace out boys I'll see you all Thursday